the event and tell you that Margaret yl
is from Class of 2002 and she works in
digital education and joy from Oh Stella
is widely known first games for learning
projects Lily a [ __ ] from the drunk
Nashville is from 2006 and Edith big
data driven consumer research Eric State
in 2020 is now PhD student at MIT
program in history anthropology science
technology and society and Chelsea
Brahmas class of 2015's the newly minted
advisor to the media labs digital
currency initiative so thank you oh gee
are we gonna go in like Yammer disorder
alright thank I have some notes so
please let me know if I'm rambling over
and can you hear me in the back I'm
gonna using my outside voice excellent
first thank you Andrew in the department
for having us all participate it's
really nice to be back so I'm gonna talk
a little bit about my life in CMS and
afterwards so I was in the second cohort
that ever went through the program and
the program was really still in flux at
that point but it was it was great and I
think I sort of slipped in before there
were more rigorous admissions standards
put in place I came from a graphic
design background and I'd sort of
slipped in into some earlier classes to
Aude it and insinuated my way in and for
which I'm very grateful and my focus was
on of all things advertising in public
space I think I can say with a measure
of confidence that I was one of the
first CMS sirs to really focus on
advertising Ilya and Sam and others have
taken it to a higher level since but and
I will say that my timing was impeccable
being in CMS so right upon graduation
there was a recession and out of my
cohort about half of them went into PhD
programs and the other half of which I
was a part sort of
you know something else to do and so
back when I was in the program there
were two primary faculty there was there
was Henry and William and we sort of
self sorted that the students to be like
Henry people are William people and had
we got the participatory culture and
fanfiction types and William did the the
more historical people and since I did
my pieces on neon signs in New York at
the turn-of-the-century New York you can
figure whose person I was but in 2005
Henry had gotten a grant from the
MacArthur Foundation on digital learning
and again I somehow sneaked myself into
the role of project manager there and so
all of a sudden I was on Team William
and team Henry and and I think the
reason I was even considers it was
because my ties to the department and
what Henry knew about me and the project
itself project new media literacies was
essentially a start-up with anima MIT in
the literature Department which is kind
of funny when you think about it and I
can say with confidence that we sort of
didn't know what we were doing and it
was a blast it was really fun to sort of
figure out really from the ground up
what we were doing and there were a lot
of hair-pulling and anxiousness and
sleepless nights and schnitz but like at
the end of the day it was really fun and
we did something really worthwhile and I
wouldn't trade it for anything so
there's something to be said for just
throwing yourself into things and
figuring it out and since then I went on
to work at harvest project zero with
Howard Gardner he's the you may have
heard of him he's one of the people who
probably know the sole person who
started multiple intelligences and
challenging the idea that there was i
q-- in one single way of thinking of
people as being smart or not
since then I've also worked in was it's
a year I have to check academic
publishers and I most recently been
working with a education services firm
which means that we bit out four clients
and we do a whole range of work from k12
to higher ed and sometimes it's
professional development and sometime
it's a little app for you know a second
grader and everything else in between
and it's funny on this panel now because
about three weeks ago I was laid off
from that job but I honestly think that
I am fine it's actually Boston is a
wonderful city to be in educational
technology there's so many opportunities
out there and I already have worked in
the pipeline and I'm talking about and I
was telling Dan that you know my big
decision now is to know like oh my god
not what I'm gonna do but how I'm gonna
do what am I gonna do because I could
contract I could get another job I don't
really know yet I have to sort of figure
it out and so just to sum up I think
that my current position now and what I
know is not necessarily per se a result
of my CMS education but is that directly
a result of working with Henry and the
faith that he put in me in that role and
that was because of my involvement with
CMS so I just also want to say that I
still love William but I'm on both team
Henry I don't think I've seen Henry and
William in the same room in a while yeah
I ran into Henry the other day I wasn't
sure if you were covertly here or not
I'm so glad you came tonight because I'm
definitely team Henry take that William
I know I love William - I know but Henry
was unlike these is commit II and past
me despite my thesis so thank you so I'm
in learning games and that's why I came
to this program because there was a
research group here called the education
arcade actually there is a research
group here called Education arcade when
I first sort of learned about this team
of people in this line of research it
was a few years before that and 2002 was
called games to teach funded by
Microsoft and
directed by Kurt's choir who's now over
at Madison so I worked a little bit with
Kurt and Philip tan who's still here he
runs the games lab and Matt Weiss who's
a previous alum on a game to teach
history called revolution and then that
was when I was still an undergrad at
UMass Amherst and then I came here to
work with education arcade and at that
point games to teach had sort of stopped
we had a new funding source tried to
reimagine it a little bit and we
coincidentally got a funding for our
project called lure of the labyrinth
which was a game to teach math and
reading to middle school students
especially at risk or disadvantaged kids
and that was great that was
transformative in every possible way
and for me that was really the the
defining aspect of coming here versus
going anywhere else one of my
frustrations with school in general is I
feel like it's practice and practice
makes me impatient I just want to do
something real and lore of the labyrinth
was this project that was real it had
real money it had a real development
shop supporting our design efforts it
had real students and so all of that was
extra motivating to you know add all the
Polish to the design possible and we had
a wonderful time working on that and
then I continued working with that group
to read the education arcade after
graduation and eventually the folks who
run that spun off a nonprofit called the
learning games Network and I've been
working with that nonprofit actually to
this day so I'm still connected and my
work is a direct outcropping of the
relationships and the reefs
Church that I did while I was a student
here so absolutely transformative for my
career my professional development I
will say one aspect that I'm trying to
build upon or improve upon from my time
here is the research projects were grant
funded and usually grants would have
money specifically earmarked for
research and development but not for
marketing and outreach so that became a
challenge of you make this interesting
thing nobody knows about it and how do
you get it out there so that was one of
the result d'etre of the learning games
Network to have a way outside of the
university that we could be a little bit
more flexible with both the revenue and
spending that also is grant funded and
has gone through ups and downs and the
downs are like year like at least a year
at a time that we don't have any money
and I have adapted my working style to
maintain that connection so I actually
started another indie game developer
company called skylight games that I run
out of my bedroom and that's a thing a
way to occupy my time while we're
waiting for new grants with the learning
games Network so I'm really excited that
we're launching our first app through
skylight games on Monday it's a language
learning game called liriko lyr Iko so I
hope you all check it out yep that's it
peace out yeah nice boy oh I work in I
work in advertising and that's why I
like you know commercial messages right
in between the speakers I wish we had
some more yeah I I came here in 2004
before that they had studied that had
been studying philosophy of virtual
culture I've learned about this program
incidentally I wanted to study I was
about to go study public relations
actually but then I read this wonderful
article about Henry
experience from the only TV show and you
know an angry moms calling about grand
theft auto and you know that you know
kind of spike the interest in this and I
thought was you know it wasn't it was a
very unique place to study something
that that was doing anyway
so you know with the dream and the
seventy extra bucks the ask around for
an application they applied kind of on a
whim I mean it you know I'm surprised it
worked out so I guess the relaxed
admission standards that was less until
2004 um here
I obviously I took the core classes and
I the the great thing about the
Institute is that you can serve go it's
like a intellectual buffet in a sense
you can go and take different classes
and kind of structure your own
curriculum
so I I took a bunch if I wanted at a
bunch of classes marketing classes at
Sloan just to see what that's like and
that was okay I wish I could I wish I
could taken other classes and in kind of
neuroscience wing because that's what I
find very useful in my work right now
but now I have to rely on Coursera and
kind of textbooks um but but at the end
you know it's that I serve put together
some foundation that's been helping me
you know for the past for the past ten
years here we work the with Sam quiz
right who is also in the audience who
worked on the convergence cultures
consortium which we started with
permission a bunch of other smart guys
and that was the kind of the commercial
that was the commercial front of the
whole same a separation that that talked
to talk to brand owners and the media
owners and we tried to unlock the kind
of the reasons why people choose the
brands that they choose and how the
popular culture influences that and
that's you know that has remained the
kind of stuff that I've that they do now
is a research at an advertising agency
where have been since since I graduated
here and you know that the the with this
benefit of a perspective now the CMS CMS
um Institute in general influences your
life differently you know kind of the
further you move away
you know initially you you come out
refreshed with all those different
perspectives and you know you you
uncover things from from from angles
that you never really even knew existed
and that's that this is one of the great
things of this place that brings
together people who otherwise probably
would never come together because they
sort of working into all the different
spheres and you know when the
Institute's name opens doors and people
serve like you know all also you might
you probably know math can you kind of
kind of look um but you know that
happens in the beginning it doesn't
really go away but that's what's
important in the beginning now that they
have to structure kind of the work of
groups of people the way CMS's structure
it has proved to be a very good model
for that as well because you know that
if you want to bring you I if you want
the group to come up with new ideas you
have to bring people who I'm not not
only people who are good at the same
thing that you are all right so but like
people who are good at different things
and you know get them together and start
talking and maybe you know if you have
somebody who studies comic books and
stuff with somebody who studies rocket
science maybe you you know some
something new will come on so that's
that's kind of my page so I'm Eric state
and I'm one of the newer graduates on
this panel so I just finished in the
spring and now I'm at a ph.d program so
my post CMS career is all of five or six
months so I'm you know definitely sort
of in this vein going to Mary from how I
got here and sort of how I see just
looking back in those couple of months
how what I've learned here is still
influencing the work that I'm doing so
just as a sort of background I'm a long
time programmer also web designer but I
did physics and under gravity we sort of
intent to go on and do an astrophysics
PhD and then sort of that would be
what I did and right at the sort of last
possible moment doing an undergraduate
thesis in lab and realizing that though
I love the material that wasn't the kind
of research I wanted to do you know for
the rest of my career I also so I had
been taking a lot of english courses on
the encouragement of a friend I took a
course in modern culture and media
studies at Brown taught by Wendy Chung
called race and / maths
technology there's quite an interesting
name and that made me sort of realise
that the literary critical machinery
that I had been developing over in
English combined with my interest in
technology that there was this
interesting space to use that to
critique modern technology modern
culture and it seemed like it would be a
good place to come learn some sort of
new techniques do some work that wasn't
traditional humanities academic work but
would be useful to me in what I continue
to do whether that was continuing in
academia or not and I really think that
it was a good thing to do to come here
for that purpose additionally it wasn't
CMS isn't a place where you're you know
though you're doing this research it's
not like your research group hands you a
master's project and says do this so
that was also really important for me
because I have just discovered this new
area of interest that seem to bring
together a lot of things but I wanted
the freedom to sort of design my own
project and figure out what to do
and so there's a lot of definitely a lot
of structured assistance here I mean the
faculty are really interested in making
sure that you're doing something you're
thinking tactically about what you're
doing and they're you know that you're
doing something that's not only
meaningful to you but has some sort of
impact in the world but it's really up
to you to you know design that project
for yourself and that was something that
seemed to really fit what I wanted
they were also of course in particular
people here who I was interested in
working with Nick Montfort at the
Choptank where I did my research
assistantship
I mean studies software studies platform
studies does sort of history material
history of computing work that was
really interesting to me and so that was
also a big factor for my coming here I
actually found the program was more
broadly useful than I had anticipated I
had a lot of good conversations with
people who were not sort of in my
technical area that had a lot of great
ideas and to remove my workaround in
ways that were really productive just to
briefly outline my thesis work because
that's still really relevant here just a
couple months gone my thesis is on
automated vehicles or self-driving cars
the way that they seem to be most often
talked about so looking at media
representations of those kind of devices
compared with the ways that they're you
know written about in engineering papers
or talked about by engineers if you go
and speak to them
and trying to figure out where are the
gaps in sort of public understanding of
those kinds of technologies and what
does that say for better ways that we
could understand our relationships to
them or other sorts of policy questions
that we need to be asking and I found
that this was you know it's sort of
different than some of the you know
other projects but I think that's
characteristic a lot of people coming
through CMS with very different you know
kinds of theses and it was useful to me
to sort of bring together the you know
science technology studies cited in the
media context I also so my second reader
and second committee member on that
thesis was David Mindell who's over in
past's the program I'm in now so I sort
of angled my work in that direction and
now that I'm at past's I'm sort of
looking around for new technological
artifacts to do some other kinds of work
with but I have two projects going on
now that I should just briefly mention
because they make the case for I think
for what my CMS experience is still
doing in my current work so one of those
is looking at driverless vehicles and
ethical frameworks for them so
utilitarianism or other sorts of ways of
thinking about ethics of these kind of
systems which could be a straight up
philosophy of technology project but one
of the main places that that discussion
is being carried out is in news articles
with rather unhelpful titles like will
your car be programmed to kill you which
I don't think adds meaningfully really
to the public knowledge about these
systems but it's interesting that that
discussion is happening in a particular
way and so that's something that I'm
trying to investigate they're also
finally getting a chance to go back and
read some of the original papers in AI
cybernetics from the 40s 50s and 60s
which could be sort of straight up
history of science but in my sort of
attempts to see how these people are at
the time defining their turns and
setting their work against each other
I'm bringing in some of the sort of
concepts about dealing with these these
papers not just as sources of scholarly
data that has media artifacts themselves
that they are you know performative
texts their rhetorical they're created
by particular people in particular
contexts and circulate in articular ways
and that they have a sort of materiality
as either dissertations collected into a
book or white papers being distributed
by RAND Corporation or MIT Lincoln labs
or something like that so trying to take
some of those media aspects seriously
while I'm doing sort of history of
science so if you want to know more
about anything else including like
strategizing master's thesis towards PhD
or anything like that please ask me the
questions that I'll hand it over to
Chelsea
so my name is Chelsea Kravitz I also
graduated in June and I graduated in
June 2015 about four months ago
and so Eric and I are in the same cohort
and I think have a lot of actually
similarities in kind of our
decision-making process and the things
that we found value in the program so I
also was considering vastly different
types of programs when I was thinking
about graduate school and to understand
that maybe it would be helpful to talk
about what I was doing before so um I
spent four or five years living in South
between South America and East Africa
where I was doing a lot of kind of what
you might consider international
development work but the work I was
doing was at very deep like kind of
fundamentally shaped by kind of a
movement that I think is heavily steeped
in Silicon Valley culture so I graduated
from Stanford started working through
this startup international development
company that does a lot with effective
altruism so this idea that there should
be rigorous and systematic ways that you
can think about approaching social
change internet like social development
things like that particularly abroad but
a huge part of that work is centered
around this idea of entrepreneurship and
fostering entrepreneurship abroad
couched in that is another narrative
around kind of the idea of human capital
development and the role that learning
plays in basically
fostering developments of teaching
people how to be entrepreneurs will not
lead to like you know kind of
exponential impacts because this one
person will now start a company that
will you know scale to this this growth
a highly scalable
you know product or service that's going
to improve people's lives and and then
you're gonna scale impact that way so I
was very much a part of that work a lot
of what I was doing was actually working
with social entrepreneurs in rural
places to collaboratively kind of
develop products and services that fit
kind of a social enterprise model so you
know enabling people to have clean water
that didn't
germs and them increasing their crop
yields literacy programs things like
this so as I was doing that work though
I started to realize kind of how I
summon that narrative some of the way we
are thinking about that social change
stuff and and there its relationship to
technology what was hard for me to
believe be doing it in the field a lot
of the things about you know especially
with the rise of mobile phones and
places like Kenya there's a huge
emphasis in trying to you know build
mobile apps to teach farmers better
farming practices teach better savings
practices for microfinance and things
like this so I got really interested in
kind of wanting to understand a lot more
deeply one how we learn and two how that
learning actually shaped our behavior
and our kind of life prospects so what
opportunities open up for us when we do
learn new things things like that so
it's considered a PhD in cognitive
psychology over at Harvard that didn't
seem to be really kind of the right path
one of Ch d also though very focused on
the individual unit of a learner right
and the cognitive process is underlying
how we learn which is fascinating and
really helps to inform and some great
critiques of some of the digital
learning movement that are out there but
not quite didn't have the system systems
level kind of thinking that I was
looking for the other program was an
edgy in the school of education at
Stanford digital digital I forget what
it's called like DTS or something I bet
somebody in here supply I do it as well
like digital city yeah what's it called
digital
yeah and was a little wary of going back
there because it also seemed like there
wasn't much of a critical approach to
kind of really understanding the what
technology role is and kind of learning
and connecting to kind of bigger issues
in equality and there's like another big
kind of narrative around the world at
school plays as like an equalizer and
playing fields that that I wasn't seeing
a lot of what they were doing was really
deeply entrenched and kind of like the
existing school system and kind of
playing technology on top of it this
program I had no idea what it was going
to be about but everybody I talked to
seemed to have really thoughtful
questions to ask me about my work even
though they weren't people who
necessarily had domain expertise and the
things that I was interested in studying
so big fear I had was that there weren't
a lot of people who could give me a lot
of in depth of guidance in my domain but
at the same time like it did seem like
the types of conversations that people
were having here we're cutting across
like a lot of like each of us I think in
our cohort for example I feel like in
our years or the years like when the
discussion of the algorithm really
started to blow up right and algorithmic
bias now control of algorithms and
things like this and it led to a lot of
really fruitful conversations within our
cohort that each of us could kind of
pull from and connect to our own work in
really interesting ways so so ya chose
this program for that when I got here
you know I think a lot of my work ended
up shifting to not so much the how do we
use technology to foster kind of better
kind of learning models whether it be
within or without of school so much is
thinking about this movement to unbundle
education break break apart and D couple
learning opportunities from institutions
like universities and things like that
and so instead of focusing on that like
this this movement unbundle higher-ed I
was really interested in kind of the
question of okay we have now a much
broader set of learning opportunities
that are starting to emerge that we
could ask consumers to choose how do we
make decisions about that part of the
way we're going to make decisions is
knowing how well that that learning
experience with that credential can
translate into real opportunities in the
labor market so a lot of my work was
looking at actually the digital badging
credentialing and issues of
credentialing that that must be answered
in order to understand the value of
alternative education models I
specifically focus on the tech industry
because that's an industry that has a
lot of resources outside of a
traditional University kind of available
to you if you want to learn how to code
and develop a marketable skill set and
while I was doing that work came across
a set of practices that are kind of
really shaping my work now which is
called passive recruitment so basically
a process of scraping data that's
publicly available on the internet and
forming dossiers of information about
individuals without their their
knowledge and selling those Doc's knees
of information to recruiters who are
looking for people to recruit for jobs
but not so selling those things and
offering basically recommendations on
who would be a good employee so a lot of
my work here you know it was really
helpful talking to people like Eric even
though Eric was working on like you know
self-driving cars I was starting to look
at civil rights issues related to
algorithmic recruitment tools and we
could get together and have really
interesting conversations about the
intersections of our
so yeah did that I was expecting we
leave here when I when I graduated I was
excited to get out of the cold but I
there at an ethical opportunity here
that I started the week after I
graduated which was a new initiative
actually based in the Media Lab called
the digital currency initiative and I
just an interest of time I won't
necessarily explain why I think that
connects to the work I'm doing now but
yeah okay cool so I was like um so you
know as I was um as I was looking at
some of the one of the things that
really kind of Concerned me when I
started looking at these passive
recruitment practices was that they
mirrored and exacerbated a lot of the
issues we've seen kind of over the last
several decades related to like credit
reporting companies so these are also
companies are in the business of
harvesting your data and selling it to
other people to inform their decisions
about you and deny or offer you
opportunities as information has gotten
more and more digital Credit Reporting
regulation has gotten more and more
difficult to implement effectively and I
think now the companies who are doing
this passive recruitment stuff their
behaviors and all intents and purposes
look exactly like what credit reporting
agencies do but it's it basically AUB's
the legal paradigms we had a place to
basically protect consumers against
erroneous data being collected and use
against them
faulty algorithms use to calculate
scores about you things like that you
know double positives have people having
the same name things like that
there was no due process kind of thing
put into place for consumers to be able
to deal with that in the ditch
and the problems are magnified and all
these like a crazy ways now because we
live like basically in a digital world
where like we as consumers have very
little control over our data and very
little we don't have the infrastructure
kind of available to us to be able to
extract value or insights from it so I
started looking and getting interested
in Bitcoin actually because I started
hearing people talk about Bitcoin
basically as a potential underlying kind
of backbone for a much more user
centered digital management
infrastructure probably won't get into
all of this right now but this means
much further beyond just financial
transactions you thinking about using
the technology underlying the Bitcoin as
a way for us individuals to be able to
manage access to our own data to
third-party providers clients built on
top of it that what want to provide us
services in a way that we fundamentally
control more than than we do now with
huge companies like Facebook and Google
basically having these big
infrastructures both hardware and
software wise to be able to harvest and
and build AI machines to control our
data sorry I wasn't planning to talk
about this too much but yeah so anyway
my master's work I think directly led to
the work I'm doing now and I'm still
sticking around because I can't suppose
this one
himself I want to ask the panelists
whenever anyone asked you a question
just to repeat it it slows things down a
little bit but we are live streaming the
event and anyone who's not really near
that microphone can't be heard so good
to repeat the question when you ask the
question if you can identify yourself
that would be great and I'm just curious
I know that Sanford is an alum of the
audience we have other alums in the
audience okay great what's your name
Sangeeta hi thanks for coming okay great
let's go
so as you guys now into the
communications for the program I'm
Andrew you guys have met yet and one of
the challenges of a program like this of
marketing is that we basically say our
niche is that we don't really have an
excuse anybody what so what I end up off
and falling back on is that we are a
Media Studies program at MIT that gets
us special is that we're at MIT so I'm
just kind of curious to hear from you
guys what is it about Institute and what
did you get out of MIT what was special
about being here for a program for two
years that you think you may not have
gotten any place else
so the repay the question is like how
should we describe the real uniqueness
of the CMS program and and particularly
specifically what is the MIT environment
really add to it yeah I think a big
window right away
I'm doing great somebody mentioned here
was it is immensely powerful to have an
at mit.edu address email address there
are a lot of people I reached out to
before this program that did never
respond to me that did respond once I
went in the program so that's one thing
but I yeah I think another thing I
really benefited from was I was in a
research group that was a joint CMS
Media Lab research group Center Pacific
media and so I really enjoyed having a
cohort of students on that side that
we're doing very different things and
had different skill sets for me but
really pushed my thinking and introduced
me to things that I wouldn't have gotten
I think that a traditional Media Studies
program I mean I think there's and for
me it's that there are just a ton of
resources here and it is easy to allow
yourself to sort of sit in a little MIT
humanities bubble and not go outside of
it but there is a huge world there if
you're sort of willing to do that to go
out there to talk to other people in
other departments I mean for me like it
was useful to have people like John
Leonard who worked on the DARPA urban
challenge project here on campus I mean
he's doing other things now but that I
was able to take a class and he like
came in and talked to our class and we
got to ask him some questions
those sorts of interactions with for my
interests in technology with you know
engineers and technical people or really
important
or the work that I wanted to do and it
was something that I had to go out and
find but that you know that is very much
here and there's a lot of history and
like great documents about you know
people like Norbert Weiner and the
archives and things like that so there
there is this sort of you know techno
science center here that for my kind of
work was particularly useful well you
you can say that you know studying media
here you study it you studied that the
source because a lot of us look the cold
media now that's it's that you know it
started within this walls from you know
from video games to you know who knows
what you know Media Lab is cooking up no
so that would be that would be an easy
answer that's very convincing problem we
could test that I like for me he it's
it's this interesting way to combine the
Institute's focus on technology you know
MIT being a technology Institute and
they kind of very humanistic aspect of
CMS you know and and it's focused not
just on abstractions and systems but on
on people and that's you know one of my
college professors said that the course
the class is successful with ten years
you know after if after if you remember
one thing you know that you know going
thinking back about college they
probably remember six things you know
after four years which is not you know I
guess not a bad return on investment if
we were to carry out carry away one
thing from you know from my extreme ass
experience is that it's something that
so simple but it's so rare in at least
in the worldwide work is that you know
people are
people have agency you know people do
things because they want to do things
and there are mechanisms within you know
our say college and you know with it
around us that you know in response to
which we do things and they're Volusia
nary reasons why we do things but
somehow when we discuss when other
places discuss medium they discuss
technology they talk about the humans
are sort of just like a thing that
that's over there and you know we have
to kind of content with their existence
but no let's talk about media and it's
very it's very difficult it's very
difficult to understand the reasons of
why things happening in the abstractions
if you don't understand you know the the
basic unit of action which is humans so
I think this combination of the
Institute of Technology and a very
humanistic and human centered program
within it you see it's a very powerful
combination in how it shapes your
thinking you know as they kind of as a
time progresses and you have to deal
with different ways of thinking outside
of it I would sort of say it's something
that I think sums up what everybody else
is said which is that it's extremely
rigorous here but one of the beauties of
the seamless program is that it's so de
rigueur that transcends boundaries so if
you were going to go into a more
traditional program it's a little bit
more of a a narrower focus in here you
can sort of do wherever your passion
takes you which is wonderful yeah just
to build on that you know I think
there's a schism in education that's a
little bit class oriented around like
theoretical or practical you know
practical is vocational is maybe for
people who couldn't cut it in the
theoretical world and theoretical then
sometimes spirals off into being so
self-contained and isolated that it's
disconnected from the world that it
attempts to examine and what I love
about MIT you know mind and hinge that
we're trying to connect the two
and I think especially what you said
about you know transcending boundaries
this is really a place where people
don't restrict themselves to the
traditional pillars or silos and that's
one of my pet peeves from my education
before coming to MIT I felt like
questions would often be asked like well
what's your background
and are you talking about something
that's outside of your background
because if so I'm gonna put you back in
line and here people were not afraid to
think about something that they didn't
have a background in and if you approach
someone else in the university people
wouldn't shut you down they would try to
support you try to connect you with
something new and I felt like at least
in the research group that I was a part
of making things and trying to lead
industry thought theoretically at the
same time was a very powerful
combination so well
that's right yeah it's mostly it's
limited to welding if you if you're
interested in other things we don't do
that the other thing I would say you all
know this Gibson scored about the future
and not being distributed equally you
know it's here well this is where it's
distributed it's right here a lot of a
lot of things we were talking is it so
fascinating a lot of things were talking
about in our group in our classes about
how things we think are working out well
you know the the real life is still
catching up to those thoughts that you
know all that work that's been done ten
years ago and that's you know that's
that's fascinating
the question
in short that's experimental
we're through the past year I learned
there are walls to the top there
there are realistic laws
so the question was about walls found at
other institutions and how in five years
from now
that's a really I mean I have no idea
but I know that whatever it is it's
gonna be really interesting and sort of
gets me here honestly and you know I'd
love to hear more about your educational
experience because I I did work at
huggsy for a number of years and you
know it is pretty siloed there and you
know coming from here where it's like oh
the astrophysicist and the speedskater
are gonna get together and invent
something new you know it's not really
like that they're at their different
roles
and out in the world if you look at it
you know if you look at it vocationally
like what jobs there are it sort of
seems like that at first
but if you if you poke a little bit more
deeply there is space for those those
people like us who are doing interesting
things sorta in between the spaces so I
think I think the future is bright and I
don't know if I answered your question
well I consider myself a social
entrepreneur so I recognize that there
are walls and I avoid organizations that
operate in that way so I did work at
Microsoft and other large companies now
I run my own company so there's a reason
for that
yeah I mean actually I do have an answer
because I'm doing the startup and if it
succeeds I'll still be doing this
startup so skylight games is a learning
game organization and the mission is to
inspire a lot of learning through Play
so our constraints are in the
marketplace because we're a business so
what can we get people to care about and
there's a million ways to think about
that
I mean for me I definitely I definitely
have a sense of that the sort of only
semipermeable walls you know nature of
these certain types of work because
ideally really what I'd like to do is to
try and sort of stand on both sides of
these sort of engineering and STS space
to you know though the reason that I'm
interested in the work that I'm
interested in is not just a sort of
arbitrary interest it's that I'd like to
think about how we can better design
systems or a better design sort of
society to cope with these sorts of
systems on the other hand that sort of
technical knowledge is important to me
for doing the work in STS but it is very
difficult you know it can be very
difficult to sort of talk to your pure
engineers and sort of make those
alternative perspectives harder I don't
have an answer for this but it's a
problem that I sort of think about a lot
I mean I guess in five years I will be
hopefully finishing you know up this
program and looking for postdocs or
other things like that I am sort of
angling for something that is in the
research space I mean like Xerox PARC is
one of my favorite sort of historical
research institutions and they don't do
a lot in this vein now that in their
heyday they were one of these places
that brought together a lot of different
people to do work that I think had you
know pretty low low barriers once you
were inside of it so there are places
like Microsoft Research that seem to
have components of that now that's sort
of what I would be
headed towards but I don't I don't sort
of have the delusion that that's easy or
simple necessarily to sort of walk on
both sides of that
so you know like the perennial phrase or
whatever is like CMS prepares you for
jobs that don't exist yet right
we kept throwing that around somewhat
bitterly is we've got closer and closer
to May 2015 and most of us didn't know
what we were doing when we graduated and
I'm just now as we've been talking
thinking about what everybody's doing
now and I would say most people have
jobs now that didn't exist when we were
in grad school like five months ago so I
mean we've got aimsley working at this
new cool division in what's supposed to
be the BuzzFeed it's a copper penny that
was growing BuzzFeed and had there has a
cool new job at the news lab with Google
which is brand new Liam got a new cool
job with Texas Monthly working in a very
fast new space for developers and news
Jesse's working in the eSports realm
which is a brand new industry you know
I'm working in Bitcoin which is fake
internet money's I think people you know
I I think that's true and I think that
the thing I wish that we had a little
bit more of was I think CMS professors
are really good at making you describe
what you're interested in over and over
and over again every time you have a
visitor every time you have a new person
come in which is really awesome I wish
we had had a little bit more training or
been nudged to do that to a slightly
broader set of audiences and I also kind
of wish we had somebody who helped us
specifically think about our job like
think about our our next step
it's it's and I don't think that will be
the best because they are specialized in
what they do they don't have the
industry connects to help you brainstorm
with like continent you should talk to
this person this person so that would be
a request and I didn't I didn't answer
the question about what I'll be doing in
five years I don't know I think that the
two things that I tried to make
decisions based on is the
interestingness of the question and then
like is there a platform that would
enable me to explore it and I have one
right now I don't know how long it'll
last
dan did you want anything
I know what what kind of walls yeah
things that we've all probably everyone
has run into like wish Department
Monsieur I just currently feel a little
bit
Washington's
right but then you'll probably
yeah just kind of
I also like people just started their
own thing and don't venture outside yeah
it's just that the great feat of fear
that I just
begin to have at this age
I feel I feel and I'm Milwaukee in a
sense that advertising in the industry
that sucks everything else in it so I
can make a good a good use of everything
has been set here you know from Bitcoin
which we have you know the self-driving
cars maybe in a couple of years so that
those walls don't really exist you know
if we see it and it has value you know
just chuck the difficult eld david the
most the car the hardest the most
frustrating wall still overcome at the
walls for the new head it's when you you
know you hit the limits of your own you
know you explore something deep enough
and then you hit the limits you know
your letter ends you know you hit the
limits of your own knowledge and then
you realize that the new letter you know
you have to complete another ph.d
program just on this temple' something
works and that's that's very dispiriting
like knowing that you know you feel like
you know something finally and then you
hit this point where like oh there is
this other room that you know you have
no idea so that's that's that's probably
a bigger problem to solve for me yeah
and i want to say it's somebody who was
laid off three weeks ago that like i
think anything that we plan for five
years from now can change very quickly
you know and I think really um there
there are gonna be new ways to combine
skills in five years there's gonna be
new ways to look at them and there's
going to be new institutions that are
they're catering to this I mean would
even thought a Bitcoin you know five
years ago like maybe some people do but
it wasn't really public you know or you
know a culture is always like this this
moving target and it's really I think
people sort of sometimes get in trouble
when they think they know what's coming
because we don't none of us really know
what's coming
one of the walls that a friend of mine
was very frustrated by actually he
didn't go to CMS but he did a PhD in CCL
and he was interested in the mind and he
would say to me that he felt like he was
born a century too soon because the
tools to examine the mind at the level
he wanted to don't exist today so
if you grab they need to be
yeah
I work in a grant-funded difficulty
happenes program and
constantly sort of thinking our
questions of innovation and what sort of
pipe index
around
I'm wondering it's not building off of
this last question many of us
okay look short
the ways that
the ways of the desert direct on working
these physics are challenging or
carriages have always kind of beam on
the urge and the ways that your time CMS
prepared you
helps you think about different ways to
sort of thing really
being on the leading edge
I place a solution aversion I would see
a mess how do you feel
how did say must help you help us deal
with the shock of the new was the
question he said it very slowly that's
why it took three minutes well just in
in my space I'll talk about you know
when I started making apps apps were new
they're not new anymore so the fastest
earliest app developers got a lot of
publicity for free by being one of a
small number of apps that's not true
anymore you could say this it's the same
thing today with VR so then if you sort
of have to decide are you an app
developer are you a VR developer you
know are you gonna switch every time
there's a new technology are you going
to continue to deepen on the technology
that you've already started on there are
elements of how much am I willing to
throw away and begin again obviously
anything in technology you have to sort
of remake yourself every few years so
people who aren't willing to do that
won't stay relevant
I think the master's thesis is really
useful for for this because you you are
attracted to these you know cutting-edge
things that could have all these big
implications and you hear at sea all
these headlines that are really
provocative and most people like to
hover at that level of conversation and
you just can't for these since you have
to like think about okay in this limited
period of time what kind of information
can I gather and look at that's going to
help me answer a specific question
that's gonna offer a new insight into
this big big thing so it helps you
really learn how to go past this
high-level speculation to thinking about
what's a thoughtful question to ask and
then making a plan yeah and I I mean I
think that that goes with what I sort of
said in my introduction about the way
that the program asks you and sort of
you know teaches you to be strategic
about what your intervention is to like
I mean one of the one of the terms that
william gurkey oh really likes is you
know mapping the fields it's like figure
out you know your your question is the
nexus of some set of things some of
which are you know maybe very old some
of which are new trying to sort of you
know get get dirty in these different
sort of discourses and figure out how I
can apply you know the ideas from you
know anthropology of magic or something
like that to this sort of you know new
technology that I want to look into and
just that sort of lateral lateral
thinking and
you're just being being pushed to do
that sort of work across different
spaces I think I mean that's something
that I'm going to sort of keep reusing
whenever I'm dealing with this sort of
it's a new it's a new device it's a new
sort of technology it's being used in a
new way how do we think about that you
know there are always there are always
long historical strands to anything that
you can sort of pull apart and then just
sort of the you know feeling some drive
like someone someone has to start doing
serious work on things even if you know
they're only something that's existed
for six months just I mean having the
space to do something like that I think
was useful and will continue to be
useful you know from my sort of more I
mean
perspective within academia so to speak
as I'm you know sitting at the start of
a ph.d program I started that was a big
fan of the future when I was here I
started I was such a big fan that I
started 2004 you know I started this
thing called a blog yeah it was very it
was actually how I got my might might my
job is like my future boss was reading
one of the few blogs that existed and
you know that very cutting edge thing
and the blog was about the future of
advertising you know so I was hunting
down like all those things that will be
happening and it made my job you know 10
years ago was to go around the clients
and explain people what Facebook is that
exists and it's this cool thing where
they should experiment them you know um
and Second Life so those were two big
things ten years ago and after what I
know we have an entire department that
sort of does the same thing but they've
all periscope well you know whatever the
new thingy I became just to be chanted
for the future and I'm glad I'm not the
one doing that stuff anymore because it
became it's becoming very frustrating
and like chasing ghosts kind of
ghostbusters right so you go around like
oh this is a new thing and then the new
thing either you know happens so maybe
it doesn't but by the time it does it's
not a future thing anymore you know by
the time it's worth paying attention to
at least you know from the business
perspective it's oh it's not the future
anymore and it's this big thing and so I
give up you know I said you know screw
the future I'm gonna focus like on
things that happen right now and you
know when it hits me it hits me and to
deal with this I started looking at kind
of the core reasons why certain things
happen you know and that yeah and once
you start looking there you understand
that people throughout you know the
humanity is fairly short history they
all they all driven by by the same
motivations and those motivations have
biological reasons and societal reasons
since once you kept that simple set of
rules you know the world becomes a lot a
lot easier to gamble
when you say the shock of the new I
don't quite know if you're referring to
technology or just a cognitive response
to change I mean what I will say about
the program itself is that I felt like I
was always being thrown into something
over my head in a good way
you know and it really depends if you're
the kind of person who says I'm gonna
swim my way out of this are you freaked
out you know I think it's you know one
of those things I was out of school for
a while when I went into the program too
so I had to relearn things like how to
write papers and well I have a pretty
direct connection as I look at Henry
sorry right so the question is about the
strength of the the network ties that
were developed in the program both in
within the program and at MIT in general
all right so yeah I mean the the time
with Henry was was strong enough to
start me on on this path that I've been
on now for 10 years but that's kind of a
very strong recommendation but it
doesn't you know that's a pretty
isolated event I mean in terms of alumni
I keep in touch with my cohort pretty
closely I had the good fortune of
actually returning to the program later
you know as a employee and I get to know
other people like dan you know younger
than me going through the program and
when you go through MIT you do get
access to all of that good stuff like
the alumni network and a great alum MIT
edu email feed and you get access to all
of the information on the alumni there
and you can go
and you can search for people who are in
your field and some of them are actually
indicated as wanting to be actively
counseling fellow alumni and so you can
just write to them which is really neat
I already sort of said I'm working with
people that I met in the program so very
strong connections with a small subset
of the network and not so connected to
the broader network especially if you're
in Boston you know all the other things
that that are true to other University
along networks they're true here as well
I mean you know you keep in touch and
you participate in things and you
participate in things like this and it's
all very you know it feels good um the
thing that's unique to a medium to
Boston is that you know when you when
you work around here you very often end
up working with companies that it turns
out where I started by somebody who was
living you know two doors down down the
hall and you know in the same dorm and
that you know the that kind of builds up
an instant connection for you that was
really cool
yeah I mean for for me I did find it
useful to have some relatively recent
alums who have gone through the program
and were either you know in the middle
of a PhD or had sort of completed their
PhD and done some postdocs
and been able to talk to them about you
know how to how to position myself what
programs I should apply to so I mean
Kevin Driscoll and Nick Seaver were both
people that I met you know alums of the
program that I met through them coming
here to give like colloquium talks or
other sorts of things and they were both
really helpful to me in my PhD search so
there's also if you're headed in that
direction there is also a network of
people who are at various stages in
academia sort of you know drawn their
perspectives and it helped these were
you know people interested in some of
the same issues that I am in different
ways and so that was useful network for
me
I don't have anything more to add
he also has a benefit you also get this
brush accidental brush with geek Silla
geeky celebrity sir anyway well yeah you
know you play Bioshock in this by you
know the third Bioshock and is totally
awesome of them you suddenly realize
that Christina used to you know wrote
scape of the dialogue for anything like
wow you know or you know the Star Wars
is coming out and you you know the guy
who's been working on the Star Wars one
aspect of it you know you've been
drinking it Charles you know 3:00 in the
morning to it so that you know that
those bragging rights they also of
course exist and those people you know
they were right in the same room with
you you know and the latest one fallout
4 he's probably off the merry familiar
with Chris Weaver it was a teacher in
the programs I was great to have that
expert in that company that's a
bottomless kind of source of bragging
rights if you like you know fallout
Skyrim and you know yeah of course I
might these evil in that game yes
Commonwealth Institute of Technology
and I Emily see I'm a second year
masters student and this is kind of a
general question because we have
students that are thinking about
vascular surgeons like machines here so
is wondering just you guys the general
tips everything that you wish you had
known before coming to CMS or a long
list I have a tip about your thesis and
somebody tells me this somebody told me
this is my first semester here so it may
be too late for you but everybody else
there's still hope which is that when
you like have in your mind sort of where
you want to go and have everything that
you produce leading towards that so if
you have a paper that's due for you know
something rather have it be on maybe one
element of what you think you've got to
be writing about down the line and it
actually I I sort of was able to do this
sort of but it you know even doing it a
little bit helped me immensely in the
production of my thesis that's a pro tip
okay oh man let me give you a totally
opposite advice I wish I hadn't taken
all those marketing classes and maybe
you know advertising classes because
that stuff you know kind of learn on the
job but read from the books and that's
you know that's easy I wish I think in
classes that I would never otherwise
read the books about you know and
architectural urban urban design or you
know say college if they give their left
knee so we should have done actually
more of that all of that but read biking
than being being absolutely focused well
it's sort of like no I took an art
course and uh you know was a history of
postmodern art or something like that
and boy like I was really out of my
element you know which was great but you
know still thinking of it I used it you
know trying to think about some of the
problems that were in my head so sort of
using everything as a jumping-off point
for the problem but it doesn't have to
be the same discipline right right yeah
yes so eventually things will arrange
themselves in your head so with you know
towards a toward toward solving a
particular problem that you end up with
but finding you know just exposing
yourself to the entirely different
disciplines has been immensely useful
I'm still waiting I took a class on the
Kim
Media during war with Beth : so I'm
still you know still waiting for that to
come in candy but otherwise the Public
Service Center gives money for cool
things I got $10,000 over the two years
I was here from them for different
projects and it's pretty easy to get it
if you can explain those potentials so
social value of the work I mean I don't
I don't know that I have much to add to
that honestly but sort of make I mean
making everything that you whether or
not you think it's gonna be useful to
you from the start making everything
useful to some you know whether it's
sort of closing off the door like now I
know like I don't want to go in that
direction yeah you know thinking about
it that way that at least if you have to
take this sort of course that doesn't
quite feel right to you
at least it's informative you know me at
all is informative and then it's maybe
less frustrating it might make sense
later yeah it might make some no manty
like as an historian I teach alive
historical material and all the way
students are more like techno futurists
and so I did about the past and I have
to believe it's amazing I think yeah
you're always comedy and like and those
like you've got super like inform
everything to have perspective about
these other massive transitions from
like one media regime
takes about seven years and you know one
of the things that Jesse brought up was
this sort of spark of sanity just
happens in a place like CMS if you start
meeting with people about things we can
work on things very different than you
which have common questions and to me it
seems that they get they use out of the
program like CMS you have to be somebody
who is integrated by that spark of
serendipity and you're looking for it
because two years is a short time and
you know a lot of people out in this
experience like I left thinking oh wow I
could have used many more years of that
and the great thing about CMS is I feel
like as a network it allows you to use
many more years of that if you want to
take advantage of it there's a cultural
anthropologist named grant McCracken
that many of you guys don't have he sort
of you just hang around CMS a lot and
they still come around from time to time
and he said he said that it's a mess I
understand my team that CMS in
particular seem to have that very
uniquely so I was just curious there's
anything for for you for you guys that
while you're here comes to mind
something that wouldn't have seemed
useful immediately but like in
retrospect I mean you kind of got at it
with talking about Taylor's forces but
you know one of their questions things
that you got introduced to things even
your colleagues were working on that you
look back on and say wow like those are
those are issues I'm
now just curious definitely for me I
ended up working really closely with a
CMS LM actually a year ahead of me
Robbi proof shot ma who came
specifically because Henry was here so
Henry was the magnet and then Ravi and I
worked on learning games and language
learning games and he introduced me to
an idea that I'm still using today which
is working with people more globally so
there was a website oDesk and Elance and
up work and you may be familiar with
this you know the gig economy that kind
of thing so our startup now is basically
entirely that way we have 22 people
across probably 15 countries so you know
I never imagined that I would work in
that way before coming to CMS but it's
absolutely been transformative and I see
it sticking and the question was sorry
about that I mean in terms of like
serendipitous things that's probably a
pretty large one I mean I have a very
small one which was just that you know
in in one of Williams classes we were
doing some or just a conversation I had
with him this sort of idea about media
archaeology came out and he suggested
you know why don't you take a look in
this like he had you know sent me this
website that has a lot of old magazine
covers and so we were looking through
like 1930s modern Mechanics magazine and
up comes this cover that says like light
beams steers super racing car and I
would never have thought to go look at
sort of this sort of Popular Mechanics
style magazine from the 30s and yet I
discovered here's this you know vision
of some kind of you know driverless
vehicle you know imagine with technology
that was sort of reasonable back then
and so that I mean that also sparked an
interest for me in how was this
technology
looked at it like various times and
caused me to do more research in that
area and you know tilt the sort of
introduction of my thesis in that
direction so that's a sort of small
example I wouldn't have gone and done
that unless I had had that conversation
with William and you know he introduced
me to that resource
I feel like he's been working on this
but it's a very complicated so I just
wish I wish I had it in a debate
training situation before this one very
polished response to that but really
think that many of us are enthusiastic
about them to see it happen we're not
quite there yet a lot of money mom do
you know and there's a lot of resources
involved just keeping a master's program
going you know which wasn't like how do
we get more down than them you know just
like making all the pieces work together
so it wouldn't be illogical kind of
steps in it's level and with regard to
debate you can't just channel your inner
William Buckley I will just it looks
like we're probably like winding down
now and I was thinking I didn't know how
to answer the serendipity question but I
was just thinking so I sort of went in
and audited one of the first courses at
CMS that um and Henry taught and had
been so long since I've been in any kind
of academic setting and we were reading
Walter Benjamin which if you're here
you've read and if you're not you will
read and it was really hard for me and I
remember I was going away with a friend
for the weekend and I said no you can't
bother me I have to read this and she
had two kids and I'm like I can't take
this and I went into a closet and I sat
down with Ben you me and I'm like
leaving it line by line but in doing so
it sort of blew my mind and it opened up
something just like a broader
understanding of what was possible and
you talk about the serendipity it's like
sometimes you read these things in your
world starts falling into place you're
like oh I understand this now this is
the coolest thing ever like the
understanding is just this high
actually a very nice dish